that wait is over
president biden holding his first formal
news conference after
64 days in office taking questions on
major issues like the border
ending the filibuster and if he will run
for reelection
the president was not asked about covid
and the new story
involving his son hunter which we're
going to talk about later in the show
also he wasn't asked about his massive
infrastructure plan
the president also though getting called
out for sticking to his written notes
and calling on reporters from a prepared
list our white house correspondent peter
ducey
did not get to ask a question the
president spent a lot of his time on
immigration in the border
take a look perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
the reason why a lot of immigrants are
coming to this country does anybody
suggest that
there was a 31 percent increase under
trump because he was a nice guy
we're building back up the capacity
that should have been maintained and
built upon
that trump dismantled i will commit to
transparency
and as soon as i am in a position to be
able to implement what we're doing
right now i make no apologies for ending
programs that did not exist
before trump became president
that have an incredibly negative impact
on
the law
president biden was also asked about the
filibuster
and working with republicans president
barack obama said he believed the
filibuster was a relic
of the jim crow era do you agree yes
you're moving closer to eliminating the
filibuster is that correct
i answered your question i have
electoral
support from republican voters
republican voters
agree with what i'm doing not true
jesse you know a lot of the critics made
a lot of the fact that
the president didn't hold a press
conference but before now
some people suggested he wasn't up to it
but there were no big gaffes and he
seemed to have a grasp of the issue
what are the critics saying now
i'm not a critic juan i'm an umpire i i
it's balls and strikes with me you know
how i play juan
but that's a pretty low bar to say he
didn't have a gaffe
or uh he seemed to have had a grasp of
the issues
guys the president united states
williams he clearly does not understand
how badly the border crisis is hurting
him and the
plan that he put in place is only going
to make it worse
and that's why i think immigration is
going to dominate the next couple months
the key word or the whole thing
he used the word accommodate
capacity he didn't say deter he didn't
use this opportunity to tell the world
caravans don't come don't come in
he said the only reason his plan isn't
working
because they don't have enough beds and
that's why they're building all this
housing
so this isn't a policy of don't come
this is a policy of
we have to keep building more beds and
homes and keep pushing you into military
installations
that's not a good policy juan and the
other part of the policy was we're going
to send kamala harris down to central
america
and create a marshall plan for central
america
kamala harris super talented super
experienced
is going to make central america so
amazing that no one's ever going to want
to leave
central america how long is that going
to take
joe said well it could take a while yeah
no kidding it could take a while
and then he said oh well when can we see
all these houses you're building for
these illegal immigrants
the answer was quote i don't know
so he actually at one point complained
that mexico
was was not taking as many family units
as he wanted them to
and then in the very same breath he said
he terminated the remain in mexico
policy
he doesn't know what he's doing and this
is a real problem
he made a false statement about
president trump said there were these
big surges under trump
no surge in 2017 no surge in 2018. he
had a big surge
and the graph shows it in 2019 trump
took strong action and it fell off the
cliff
the biden surge right now is way above
it look at the green
absolutely on pace to knock trump surge
in 2019 out of the ballpark
so the three things at the end which
were small
he read notes the whole time he can't
discuss
our policy in the pacific with regards
to north korea and china
without reading notes that his handlers
gave to him that's a little scary
he also short-circuited at one time when
he was talking about the filibuster
just gave up mid-sentence i've never
seen anything like that before
and just the reporters they are
activists
he got four questions on when are you
going to nuke the filibuster
so we can drive home socialism i don't
remember
people asking trump when he had both
chambers
when are you going to nuke the
filibuster so you can initiate tax cuts
in the wall
these people are encouraging joe biden
to nuke the filibuster and push
socialism
and they didn't call on ducey and that
wasn't right he's chicken
all right so dana uh immigration as
jesse was just suggesting was the hot
topic
biden said trump was the reason for the
surge
and he had no apology for ending trump's
programs
did he handle this well in your opinion
i think on the border
i i think immigration actually he had
his weakest comments on
that issue and also there were a lot of
questions about that issue i thought his
response about uh cecilia to cecilia
vega's question she's abc news about the
nine-year-old child that she met
and i watched her broadcast the other
day and she was quite affected by it the
way he initially answered i thought was
quite flippant and didn't take it
seriously enough
um so the other thing that happened juan
is that
of course you knew that people from the
right would um
criticize the president or be an umpire
um
and you knew that the media issue was
going to be won but
i didn't expect this a media criticism
also coming from the left
and what were they complaining about
including the white house chief of staff
complaining that there was not a single
question about covid
which i thought was very interesting
because kovid
people in a in the country believe it's
getting better what do they see as a
crisis
the border and so if i were the
president i would have had a much
stronger piece of news
to announce today about the border maybe
he could have held back the kamala
harris taking over the border news until
today at least that
shows some sort of forward movement uh
so i would say that was a little bit of
a swing and a miss
and i'll stop here but with one last
thing i just wanted to mention i did
this is not about biden or anybody this
is just about the the whole press corps
and the white house so when i was a kid
i used to love to watch
press conferences and there wasn't there
wasn't a woman
in the press briefing room when i was a
kid um
and and not working no one was working
in the white house either and now that's
completely flipped
i just thought that was kind of notable
and remarkable to see
maybe deuce you should grow from you
katie the president also said that he
felt republicans
are abusing the filibuster in a gigantic
way
and he wants the filibuster weak and
maybe even ended
what did you make of this
well i think joe biden put himself in a
box today when it came to the filibuster
by saying that he believes it's a relic
of the jim crow era because then
inevitably if that's what it is he has
to
agree that they should get rid of it but
let's talk about
his accusation that republicans are
abusing the filibuster if he's going to
say
it's a relic of the jim crow era let's
go back in history for a minute
and remember that robert byrd who is a
democratic senator
used the filibuster to filibuster the
1964 civil rights act
and guests who spoke at robert byrd's
funeral in 2010.
well that was joe biden and robert byrd
was an actual kkk member
last year senate democrats used the
filibuster
to go after and to get rid of tim scott
republican from south carolina
his criminal justice reform bill and he
is the first african-american senator
from a southern state
since reconstruction so to throw that
out there really is divisive in a time
that they're talking about unity
one thing on the border i want to talk
about real quickly is biden says he's
not going to give a timeline on when
he's letting
these reporters in to take photos what
they're doing is this they're not
allowing people into the cbp facilities
they're opening up military
installations so they're going to wait
until they empty out all those
facilities to the military installations
bring in the reporters and say look
there's no crisis here
there's no overcrowding there's nothing
to report on this
that's propaganda and i think we should
call him out on it
so greg i think a lot of people were
surprised to hear the president say yeah
he's running for reelection
uh to say also he thinks that china we
got to hold him accountable he said
schools
you know should be open uh close to
reopening more of the k
through eight and coronavirus 200
million
vaccinated by his first 100 days but
what about announcing that he's running
for re-election
what about uh what he said when he
started uh the speech juan when he said
he was elected
not to divide and then he said he wasn't
sure if there would be a republican
party
uh we should have kept that we should
have had that on tape but um
i don't even know what that means i'm
not sure
that there's going to be a republican
party have the democrats and media
decided that now they're going to cancel
the republican party
i mean this is kind of kind of rich
coming from the party of slavery
and let's be very very specific about
that okay
the democrats in the media are now doing
this thing where they're referring to
the filibuster as
a relic of the jim crow era
well do you know what else is a relic of
the jim crow era the democratic party
so if you're going to cancel the
filibuster you're going to have to
cancel
the democratic party you got to change
the name
because it's disgusting and it's
shameful that you still hold on to it
but i want to go back i want to i want
to go back and give you an assessment of
everything i saw
including before the presser it reminded
me of being a kid in the 1970s
waiting for evil knievel to commit to
one of his stunts
you know will he pull it off you know
can he make it over the snake river
canyon or will he go down
in flames uh of course um
that's a low bar right it's a quite a
contrast with trump
it was will he stand up to the press
with joe it's
will he stand up you know and he's lucky
he's lucky the 100-day build-up you know
lowered the
expectations combined with his
absenteeism and his incoherence
so it became a victory that he didn't
show up in a bathrobe you know with a
live raccoon on his head
so he did pass his first presser but he
might have passed his last one too
i would say that as an infomercial for a
life alert
it was pretty good as oppressor it
sucked he was abandoning his senses
like they were teens at the border juan
and please
we haven't even talked about the pbs
softball question
oh you know why they're coming joe it's
because you're so
awesome why are you so awesome well uh
alcindor
this is a presser it's not a bachelor
rose
ceremony okay
so i thought it was hilarious thank you
well you enjoyed it okay coming up
new york governor andrew